we have some good news from dr fauci i
never thought
i would say that but dr fauci just
appeared on my pal
alex michelson's show and fauci
said that he does not predict that there
will be
a vaccine mandate take a listen the fact
is
from the standpoint of practicality
there is merit to that
there are a lot of concerns and
objections about discrimination for
people who don't
or big brother looking over you and
giving you the
the right or not to enter into a theater
or into a restaurant
it's a very controversial issue right
now
but you could understand that there may
be individual
independent entities not at the level of
the federal government
but there may be some school districts
that would say
unless you're vaccinated you can't get
in or
some places of employment that say
unless you're vaccinated you can't come
in that's apart
from a broad umbrella concern or
control by the federal government i
don't think you're going to see
a federal government mandate about that
now that is at least something of a good
prediction
the problem for anyone familiar with dr
fauci's predictions
is they've all turned out to be wrong so
that's not great but
even taking the answer for what it is
what that means is that now this issue
of vaccine passports is up to the
governors i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
seekerfinder who says sometimes the
shepherd has to be a lion
in order to scare the wolves away very
very good point
this referring i think to that polish
canadian pastor
who screamed at the cops who tried to
break up his holy week service
and said get out get out you gestapo
you nazis get out it was just absolutely
fabulous that's right
you know the the good shepherd
uh is a very nurturing and loving
and wonderful also kind of a tough guy
also stands up also has courage
and that is what we need from from our
shepherds here as well
no question about it if you want to feel
strong if you want to feel well if you
want to feel
virile you might want to check out hims
for hims.com is all about
men's wellness need help with ed hair
loss or have a cold
interested in mental health or covet 19
home tests hymns is here for you
hymns connects you with a licensed
medical professional online who can
prescribe fda approved prescription
medication to treat ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill
but without the expensive price tag this
could cost hundreds of dollars if you
had to go through a doctor or a pharmacy
not so with him hims makes it simple and
affordable no embarrassing conversations
no expensive appointments i know that
guys don't want to talk about this sort
of thing
just answer a few questions online about
your medical history and a provider will
confidentially review
if approved your medication is shipped
directly to your door in discrete
packaging
and shipping is free you know there are
problems that really affect some guys
where there's a simple solution so avail
yourself of that solution try hymns
today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to for hymns.com michael for your
free visit
that's for hems.com michael for hims.com
michael prescription products are
subject to medical provider approval
require an online consultation with
medical provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that's for hims.com
michael the issue of the vaccine
passports is
up to the governors the good news on
this is more and more
republican governors seem poised to come
out strongly against the vaccine
passports
governor tate reeves in mississippi
is now joining ron desantis in saying
no we oppose these co-fed passports
do you think private businesses should
be banned
from requiring vaccine passports what's
your take on this
well i don't support vaccine passports i
don't think it's necessary and i don't i
don't think it's a good thing to do
in america great answer and tate reeves
has been really good
on this issue he's a good governor
generally but he's been really good on
this issue
in particular but we're going to have to
get more specific here because jake
tapper's question was very specific he
said
do you support the right of businesses
of private organizations to require
these vaccine passports
and governor reeves gives this broader
answer he says i do not support vaccine
passports
so certainly that would seem to imply
that he doesn't support them at the
state level
you know the state mandating the taxes
certain government services
you need to show a vaccine passport and
it would i think it he is saying that he
does not support it private business is
doing that either but it is a slightly
different question
and i think that we're going to need to
get real real specific on this
because i could see all the republicans
being against the state mandate but i
could see some squishes
going in for allowing private businesses
to require it but we cannot permit that
folks
if it is the government telling me that
i've got to show my medical history
and get injected with this thing in
order to participate in civil life
or it's a private business doing that i
don't really care
i just don't want to do it i will not
support any republican in the
2024 presidential primary who does not
vigorously oppose the vaccine passports
i think this is a good rule the the good
news for
people in the senate and people in
congress is it seems to be a non-issue
for them if
fauci is right then this is not going to
be a federal matter
but this is going to affect governors
because governors are going to have a
whole lot of say over whether or not
they are going and people in state
houses and state senators and that sort
of thing
presumably state senators and state
assemblymen are not going to be running
for president but the governors really
might
this is a total line in the sand issue
there are many reasons why we should all
oppose these vaccine passports
and some parts of the right are going to
gravitate towards certain reasons
some parts of the right are going to
gravitate toward others so you can you
can imagine the real
you know get off my lawn libertarian
right they're going to oppose these
vaccine passports
as a matter of liberties you don't get
to do this folks
you don't get to demand not only that i
get injected with the shot
but that i prove that to you everywhere
i go just to go buy a cup of coffee
for the maybe less libertarian more
traditional
conservatives on the right this is a
complete upending of our political order
this is an upending of our political
institutions our traditions our american
way of life
for the religious right there are
ethical questions about these vaccines
which vaccines were developed using old
stem cell lines from aborted babies
lots of bioethical questions here i
don't care which argument
you gravitate toward this is
the issue ron desantis down in florida
has been i think the leader as far as
governors go on this issue and it's why
the left is going after him did you see
this
yesterday i i hope you saw this i know
that very few people who listen to this
show watch 60 minutes
because very few people generally watch
60 minutes anymore
and hopefully it'll be fewer and fewer
moving into the future
60 minutes total network news
hit piece on ron desantis
60 minutes played an exchange between
one of their reporters and ron desantis
on an issue not really only tangentially
related to the vaccines
it's about an allegation of corruption
and whether
a supermarket chain donated some money
to ron desantis in florida and so
desantis gave them a special contract
on the vaccine it's total bs it's
completely bogus which we'll get to in a
minute
but just listen to the exchange as 60
minutes presents it
we wanted to ask governor desantis about
the deal but he declined our request for
an interview
we caught up with them south of orlando
publix as you know donated a hundred
thousand dollars to your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccination
so first of all that what you're saying
is right how is that not paid that's a
fake narrative
i met with the county mayor i met with
the administrator i met with all the
folks at palm beach county and i said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publics and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
but melissa mckinlay the county
commissioner in the glades told us
the governor never met with her about
the public's deal
the criticism is that it's paid a place
it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about
the facts because obviously i laid it
out for you in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not isn't there
no no no you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong that's actually a fact
okay wow if you were to listen to that
exchange i think you would say
gosh maybe he there is some corruption
here because he didn't lay it out in a
way that's irrefutable
he didn't take her through anything he
just made this claim that he met with
some mayors and
county people and then some other county
person said they did and then
and there were some really good shots of
the reporter smirking at
desantis and saying this is corruption
okay right that's interesting
thankfully we have the full
footage of that exchange which
went nothing like what that clip would
suggest
i'm not even going to play the whole
exchange just take a listen to the first
part of the exchange and compare it to
what 60 minutes aired
so first of all that what you're saying
is wrong that's that's a fake narrative
so first of all when we did the the
first pharmacies that had it were cvs
and walgreens
and they had a long-term care mission so
they were going to the long-term care
facilities
they got vaccine in the middle of
december they started going to the
long-term care facilities
the third week of december to do ltc's
so that was their mission
that was very important and we trusted
them to do that
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other retail
pharmacies publix walmart
obviously cbs and walgreens had to
finish that mission and we said we're
gonna we're gonna use you as soon as
you're done with that
for the publix they were the first one
to raise their hand say they were ready
to go
and you know what we did it on a trial
basis i had three counties
i actually showed up that weekend and
talked to seniors across four different
publics
this goes on for like a minute and a
half in addition to what we've already
heard
where he's laying out step by step
exactly the plan
say no we didn't give this exclusive
contract to publix we started at cvs we
start then went to walgreens then we
opened it up
publix was the first one that could do
it we did polls of the senior citizens
we found out most senior citizens live
within a mile of publix it's proven very
popular it's why we're leading the
country and these
goes on and on and on and on the
reporter has nothing and then she keeps
coming back and saying
well but this is bad and he says okay
well i've disabused you of this
narrative
i guess you're not paying attention but
i've just laid it out for you
absolutely people should lose their jobs
over what just happened in 60 minutes
whatever producer or reporter quote
unquote put that thing together
should be fired and should never work in
reporting again
if they want to become leftist
commentators on msnbc that would be
more honest more understandable but
what they just what they just did on 60
minutes is lie
they committed fraud on 60 minutes why
are they doing this to desantis
they're doing it to him because they're
afraid of him
because they think that he would be a
formidable presidential candidate in
2024. it's the same reason they're going
after cruz
for cancun i the whole time i maybe i
mentioned this at the time when when
the cruise in cancun story was the
biggest story in the world
why why was everybody going after cruz
all the time because the left felt that
he would be a formidable candidate in
2024 they're doing it to desantis
because he also
would be a formidable candidate in 2024.
they only go after people that they're
afraid of you're not going to see
60-minute hit pieces
on john kasich frankly if if the left
is not going after a republican
politician i am skeptical of that
politician
i'm probably not going to support that
politician and i think
you know i don't anticipate that there's
going to be some big expose on mitt
romney let's put it that way
okay desantis right now
is one of the big targets there are two
or three big targets on the right
he's one of them and he's stating with
clarity this is not just about
government mandates on the vaccine this
extends to private businesses
as well you know one private business
that i really like
paint your life if you want to give a
one of a kind gift a really
really meaningful gift you gotta try
paint your life.com i absolutely
love it you can get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price choose from
a team of world-class
artists and work with them until every
detail is perfect
user-friendly platform lets you order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait
in less than five minutes you just send
in any picture or pictures by the way
of you of your kids of a special place
of a pet or wherever you want
if you do multiple pictures they can
combine them into one painting this
makes a great wedding present i gave one
to my stepbrother it's a beautiful
beautiful piece
it also makes a good you present that's
what i did i had a portrait made of my
mother
it's a beautiful piece i really love it
now
a cute little june my son gets to see
his grandmother
at paintyourlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed
right now as a limited time offer you
get 20 off your painting that is
twenty percent off and free shipping to
get this special offer text the word
michael to sixty four thousand that's
mich ael to sixty four thousand text
michael to sixty four thousand go check
them out i love these guys celebrate the
moments that matter most
term supply available at painterlife.com
terms that's texting
michael to 6400
i want to be crystal clear on this
vaccine issue because i think that the
vaccine passports it's an actual line in
the sand issue
i think that republicans who do not
oppose this vigorously should not be
taken seriously
for 2024 this is going to come down to
the state houses
so i'm really talking about the
governors here
this is first of all at the bare minimum
these these guys need to come out
against state mandated vaccine passports
but they need to go further than that
actually
they need to ban businesses
from demanding vaccine passports
but michael that's an incursion into the
free market uh not really it's just
a basic defense of justice and our
constitutional order and our rights
desantis has been good on this he stated
with some clarity that he would not
tolerate companies requiring these
vaccine passports he says that would
seem to extend beyond a private issue
and of course this is the case of course
this is the case
you know at least for the past 20 years
or so
republicans and conservatives have
deluded ourselves and pretended that
there's this perfectly neat distinction
between
the public sphere and the private sphere
you know the private sector
and the the politics and the culture
that there's this perfectly neat
separation but there isn't obviously
politics in its most basic sense old
uncle aristotle taught us this
is how we all get along together it's
what we all do together and
in our political tradition we carve out
broad spaces
where the government is not or at least
the federal government is not really
expected to intrude
even though from the very beginning of
our country local government has had a
huge say about
supposedly private matters but someone
wrote in to me and i thought it was a
good question
i said michael how can conservatives
support legislation that would prevent
businesses from demanding the vaccine
passport
but also defend the baker in colorado
who doesn't want to bake a cake for a
gay wedding
again you know i don't even know what
terms we're supposed to use anymore
there is not a contradiction here the
reason that there is not a country
because on the surface it seems like
there's a contradiction
we're saying in the one case in colorado
that businesses should be able to do
whatever they want
but we're saying in the case of vaccine
passports businesses should not be able
to do whatever they want
well how is this not a contradiction
because politics has
both form and substance
so there is the question the really
abstract question should businesses be
able to do whatever they want
and then there's the substantive
question what are the businesses
doing in the case of the baker in
colorado
you have an artist right a cake artist
a man who is using his craft and his
skill and
the question is can you or should you
compel him
to do something that violates his
conscience and specifically
that violates the traditional views of
christianity
and i think the answer to that really
specific question is
no you shouldn't you shouldn't force a
christian baker
to adopt the religion of wokism not just
because of the abstract principle but
also because christianity is better than
wokism
and it's more in keeping with our actual
political traditions in this country
with regard to the vaccine passports and
private businesses
the question is should businesses be
permitted
to demand your medical history therefore
to demand that you show your medical
history to big tech companies who are
developing these
these vaccine passports should they
require
should the businesses be able to require
you to get this
very hastily developed vaccine that was
developed in the last six months
or rather within six months within the
last year
or you know a vaccine that has not by
very definition
has not been tested for long-term
consequences should on that particular
substantive question should the
businesses be able to do that and i
think no
but michael if you start talking about
the substance if you start talking about
the actual
practical issues at play why then you're
no better than the left
no i don't think so i think
conservatives are really good
at defending very abstract principles
over the last 20 years sometimes they're
defending principles they shouldn't even
defend by the way
but they've gotten really bad at
defending anything practical
anything prudent anything oh i don't
know conservative
they're not they're not really good at
that desantis has this right
a lot of other people have this wrong
where are the other governors on this by
by my last count there are 27
republican governors right now so far
i've seen desantis and tate reeves come
out
pretty strongly against this stuff where
are the other ones
i want to hear from all the other
republican governors
i just saw the the governor of arkansas
this guy asa hutchinson he just vetoed
a transgender bill
it's a there was there was a bill that
was passed through the arkansas state
house
that said that little children should
not be pumped full of cross-sex hormones
and asa hutchinson the republican
apparently republican governor of
arkansas vetoed the bill
this guy asa hutchinson thinks that
little kids should be pumped full of
cross-sex hormones
something tells me governor hutchinson
could benefit from the attachment of a
few biological
structures that he apparently lacks but
while we're waiting for that medical
procedure to take place he should be
removed from office
he has no judgment the re the reason
that issue in particular matters
is because if if you do not it ties in
with the the question of substance
actual moral arguments that we're
talking about if you do not possess
the judgment to know that you shouldn't
pump little boys full of cross-sex
hormones
to to make them look a little bit more
like little girls before they go through
puberty if you
if you don't have that judgment you
should not hold any public office you
should not be elected dog catcher
and i think that republicans should move
as swiftly as they possibly can
to remove asa hutchinson from office in
arkansas
absolutely ridiculous stuff
because they're all living in fear
they're living in fear of being called a
bigot or a thisist or a thatis what
hutchinson said was he said
this this transgender bill this is just
a product of the culture war
so what so you're going to concede the
culture war cool thanks buddy
good grief i you know i hope that
president trump lives a long life very
long life and then i hope when he goes
to his eternal reward i hope that he
donates his body
to science and his spine to republicans
because
it's pathetic what some of them are
doing speaking of instilling fear
black lives matter is threatening to
burn down the country again
if they don't get the outcome they want
in the trial of derek chovin the cop who
was involved in the death of george
floyd
there is a woman i've never heard of her
but apparently she's popular on social
media
maya eckles she's a model and a black
lives matter
activist and she just took to tick-tock
and
threatened to burn some stuff down if
they don't get the outcome they want in
the trial
if george floyd's murderer is not
sentenced
just know that all hell is going to
break loose
don't be surprised when buildings on
fire
that woman is a terrorist right
i'm not using hyperbolic language here
terrorism
is the targeting of civilians to achieve
political purposes so i guess she didn't
specify which buildings would be on fire
but if if you can infer from the way
that blm torched the country
last summer if you can infer from that
and deduce
that there would be private buildings
private businesses on fire as well as
government buildings
then what she is doing is
making a criminal threat to burn places
down
if we do not subvert our justice system
to give her what she wants
why are we tolerating what is the
the most basic definition of terrorism
why why are people going along with this
why is mitt romney
marching with blm terrorists
why is he doing that why are these rep
i never want to hear another word
about the capitol hill riot so long
as people like this lady can get away
with making criminal threats
and in the case of blm and antifa
actually carrying out threats
as they did for six months in the united
states
i don't want to hear a peep about it
about
the trumpest insurrectionists i just
i just don't want to hear it because
it's so disingenuous it is in such
bad faith and it's not just some
lady mouthing off on tick tock i mean
she identifies herself with the
organization right she identifies
herself with the blm movement
but it's not just her it's not just some
mouthy millennial
making idle threats this sort of thing
is supported
by the most powerful people
in the democrat liberal establishment
how many democrat politicians voiced
their support for blm last summer as
they burned down the country
kamala harris the sitting vice president
raised money to bail these people out of
jail
she wasn't bailing the peaceful
protesters out of jail the peaceful
protesters weren't in jail
the arsonists and the criminals were in
jail and she raised money to bail them
out and then she went on national
television
and said this shouldn't stop this should
keep going
joe biden's staff members raised money
for these criminals
and yet we are supposed to clutch our
pearls
over donald trump's tweets or something
give me
a break gosh it makes me so tense when i
just need to feel a little i can use a
little massage you know what i could get
a massage in right now my extra
x-chair has you covered for your office
chair needs the secret is
not only their patented dynamic variable
lumbar support
which offers incredible lumbar support
to your lower back
but now thanks to their new xhmt
technology
you can also get heat and massage
therapy while you're sitting at your
desk i'm not joking
when we got the chair here i immediately
try it out
i did not know chairs could be this
sophisticated but you go you get it on
you get the massage thing going get a
little heat oh my gosh it feels great
my posture feels a little bit better
helps increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy
all the perks that make working from
home or the office a joy it's even got
four different massage modes fast
forming heat technology
for therapy when you are sore right now
x chair is on sale for 100
off go to xchairknowles.com that is the
letter x
chair canon wlas.com or call one
eight four four four x chair extra has a
30-day guarantee
of complete comfort but you are going to
love it so you're not going to return it
you can finance your purchase for as
little as 30 bucks a month go to
exchairknowles.com right now use code
x wheels for free x wheel blade casters
externals dot externals.com also
speaking of the biden administration's
corruption and radicalism
make sure you check out ben's show ben
we'll be talking about joe biden's new
world order
and of course then after that we will
have the candace owens show
candace's show streams on fridays at 9
pm eastern 8 pm central dailywire.com
you can get the audio podcast though
canvas on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcasts
if you need some candace owens in your
podcast feed look no further
head over to apple podcasts or spotify
and subscribe today
be sure to leave a five star review if
you like what you
hear check it out we'll be right back
with a lot more
the mainstream left defends
embraces sometimes directly joins
the fringes of the far left and then
they run away from responsibility when
they get called out for it so
jen saki just had to do some damage
control for joe biden joe biden
came out and he effectively called for a
boycott of georgia for the
major league baseball for the all-star
game now the all-star game is leaving
georgia
and they're taking away lots and lots of
money and economic opportunity and now
people are very upset about this
including democrat politicians
in georgia so jen saki was asked about
this says gosh you know
does joe biden regret what he did and
and she
just denied his statement outright so he
was not
dictating uh for what major league
baseball
uh should do that that they should
dictating they should move the all-star
game
uh that is was their decision they made
that decision and as he stated earlier
he certainly supports that
we've not uh not asked corporations to
take specific actions that's not
our focus here our focus is on and
continuing to convey that it's important
that voting is easier
not harder that when there are laws in
place that make it harder we certainly
express an opposition to those laws
and we all believe private sector
entities are going to make decisions and
that's their uh their role to do so uh
what i'm conveying what i can speak
to is what our focus is on and what our
role is here from the white house and
what his energies will be directed
toward
so joe biden never said that that mlb
should pull the all-star game he never
said it
okay that's a conspiracy theory that he
would have said that stop it
stop accusing him of saying things he
didn't say joe what say you
said mr president what do you think
about the possibility that baseball
decides to move their all-star game
out of atlanta because of this political
issue
i think today's professional athletes
are acting incredibly responsibly
i would strongly support them doing that
people
look to them they're leaders look at
what's happened
with the nba as well look what's
happened across the board
the very people who are victimized the
most
are the people who are the leaders in
these in these various sports
and it's just not right this is jim crow
on steroids what they're doing in
in georgia mr president would you
support the mlb pulling their all-star
game out of georgia
i would strongly support them doing that
i would strongly
support them doing that he never said
that
no according to jen saki joe biden never
said what we just heard him say
and why would he support them doing that
because he says that the new georgia law
is jim crow on steroids now there's an
irony here because one of the places
that
mlb could move the ulster game would be
new york except there's a little snag
here
new york has more restrictive voter laws
than georgia
even after the georgia awful jim crow
law
so if if georgia is jim crow what does
that make
new york if republican georgia is jim
crow on steroids then new york
must be the antebellum south but it's
run by democrats how weird is that i
guess like the antebellum south
it was run by democrats isn't georgia
now sort of
right it's there's a republican governor
but there's two
democratic senators not the first time
that a biden has tried to avoid
responsibilities
uh responsibility for his mistakes
there's a an even clearer example than
old joe that would be hunter hunter
biden
who everyone's talking about his sex
scandals right now because he's got lots
and lots of sex scandals and they're
gross and some of them
are probably criminal and lots of them
are just
immoral and creepy and weird but he's
got lots of criminal issues too the
drugs
and the possible materials on his laptop
anyway the real scandal is that joe
joe biden's son hunter leveraged his
father's name
to get oodles and oodles of money out of
foreign governments that joe
biden was making policy on at the time
ukraine china he was leveraging that
name to get very lucrative deals and in
some cases he succeeded
so because joe biden's son
is in legal trouble he's being asked if
is he going to cop a plea deal is he
going to
try to get out of this federal
investigation he's under and hunter
biden says
absolutely not he's not going to cop a
plea deal he's going to maintain his
innocence
because he is 100 certain that the doj
will clear him there's a current
department of justice investigation into
your finances
what is it about can you say anything i
can't but
i can say this is i'm cooperating um
completely
and i am absolutely certain 100 certain
that at the end of the investigation
that i will be
cleared of any wrongdoing you're 100 i'm
100 certain of it and
all i can do is cooperate and and trust
in the process
he of course he's 100 certain i'm just
about 100
certain too that he'll be clear not
because i don't think that he committed
crimes i think it is
pretty clear that hunter biden committed
crimes
but he's a he's a biden he's about he's
been getting away with this for years
there there have been reports that other
peaks into his private life and his
finances
and possible crimes by federal agencies
have been covered up
over the years he's been getting away
with this for so long
why would that change now why would that
change now that his father is president
i just don't buy it the federal agencies
have been covering up for the democratic
establishment for a long time because
in many ways they're captured by the
democratic establishment
the other you know watching that
interview of hunter biden it also
reminds me don't do drugs
don't try i know it seems like a simple
thing to say
you know it's it's like i'm a i'm an
instructor in dare
don't do drugs kids not not even once
this is your brain on drugs
that interview reminded me of the
charlie sheen interviews from 10
years ago remember when charlie sheen
came out he was talking about how he's
he's got tiger blood and he was all
crazy and he looked like he was all
coked out all the time
that kind of jittery awkward it's not
the way you want to be
it reminds me that vice warps you not
just the drugs but all sorts of vice
warps you
hunter biden is a handsome guy who was
born with
virtually some sadness in his life
obviously but
basically every privilege that a guy
could have
and he turned out rotten he turned out
just about as rotten as it gets
because of vice and now he doesn't look
good either he looks
ugly he has been contorted and corrupted
by vice
and sin these are real things and these
are real things that we think about
during holy week and during easter don't
do it
don't do not end up like hunter even
though he's probably going to
get away with his crimes as a matter of
the law as a matter of law enforcement
but you can see them on his face he
doesn't look good he has not aged
very well why is he going to get away
why is hunter going to get away with
this stuff
because there's two sets of rules in
this country there's one set of rules
for the in crowd
call them the elites call them the
establishment called whatever you want
and there's another set of rules for
everyday americans and that's just that
there's one set of rules for illegal
aliens
who are being used by the democrat
establishment to
gain political power and there's another
set of rules for americans
so americans for a year i've been told
can't leave your house
can't have christmas can't have
thanksgiving don't see your family can't
have a funeral for your dead loved ones
now if you do leave your house you need
to test negative for covid you have to
show a passport to prove you've gotten
the vaccine and the variants and the
whatever
but if those same people
they left their house and they
immediately went to mexico and then they
ran across the border illegally they'd
be fine
there's an estimated 10 percent of
illegal aliens entering our country
right now having coveted
10 1 in 10 of the record number of
foreign nationals flooding into our
country
and even when they do get caught very
often they're released
have covid many of them were released
without even being tested
as the dhs secretary admitted a couple
weeks ago
that's fine that's okay we don't need to
worry about covid when it's involving
people who might give democrats more
political power we just need to worry
about covid
when it's people who might challenge
that democrat hegemony two sets of rules
speaking of dubious public health
policies
rachel levine mr dr
rachel levine is the assistant secretary
of health and human services rachel
levine is a
man who pretends to be a woman
and we are all impelled or compelled to
pretend that he is a woman as well
there was a question raised by rand paul
when rachel levine was up for his
position
that was whether or not rachel levine
would have
any sort of objectivity on the question
of
giving little boys cross-sex hormones to
make them look a little bit more like
little girls
and fundamentally damage their biology
their biochemistry because
rachel levine has this psychological
disorder whereby he thinks that he's a
woman he very much wants to be a woman
and he pretends to be one
and rachel levine said no absolutely i
can be totally objective it's totally
fine well now rachel levine who will
speak on these matters because he's the
assistant secretary of health
is coming out and supporting i guess not
really all that different from the
republican governor of
arkansas whatever he's worth rachel
levine is now supporting giving
the little kids the cross-sex hormones
here he is describing
the reasoning many states across the
country
are considering and passing bills that
would outlaw puberty blockers and
hormone treatment for transgender youth
i mean you worked in pennsylvania as a
pediatrician you understand adolescent
medicine
well how do you view these bills well i
think that they're very challenging i
think it's really challenging to see
state legislators and certain governors
targeting lgbtq
people particularly vulnerable
transgender
youth and so i will do everything i can
to advocate
for transgender and lgbtq youth to
educate
people and states about lgbtq and
specifically transgender issues
and and work towards fairness and
equality well see i don't think that
this is a political issue at all
this is about fairness and equality
and about specifically health equity
which is part of my portfolio
this is not a political issue at all wow
how brazen that is whether or not we
should have laws that allow perverts to
pump little kids full of cross-sex
hormones that's not a political issue
because it's so obvious that we should
that's that's what he is implying here
you say it's so
obvious that we should pump these little
kids full of the wrong hormones
and delay or prevent their puberty and
and mutilate their bodies it's so
obvious that it shouldn't even be
a topic of legitimate political debate
we should just go right ahead and do it
this is the progressive
view of politics which is that
everything is political except for
politics
every your sneakers are political your
tacos are political your baseball is
political
but politics is not that's going to be
decided by experts
specifically scientists specifically in
public health
you know experts who are clearly have a
lot of expertise and are so wise
like this man rachel levine
who calls himself a woman that we need
to basically outsource all of our
politics to them
and then we don't need these crazy
debates anymore it's just a matter of
equity
it should go without saying that in no
healthy country would rachel levine be
the assistant secretary of health
it is obvious it it should go without
saying now
i think it must go without saying i'm
not sure that i'm allowed to say that
am i allowed to say that it is
objectively disordered
that this guy is the assistant secretary
of health
not just because of what he says on this
one issue but more broadly am i
i don't know that i'm allowed to say
that anymore
because social media companies have gone
full in on this everyone seems to be
going in
i mean not the majority i think the
majority of the american people don't
think you should pump little johnny full
of hormones to make him look like little
jane
so then how is this being advanced even
by some squish republican governors like
the guy in arkansas
because as i describe in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
the left is engaged in a century-long
war of position
whereby they don't need to make the
arguments individually
it's not like a normal it's not like a
war of maneuver where they just lob
their argument and then
they're refuted and you go back and
forth they've engaged in a war of
position
where they attain positions of influence
throughout the society
not just in government but in
universities notably big big corporate
america
big tech elsewhere and then
gradually then suddenly they they
exercise that power
and the people are overwhelmed the
common sense is overwhelmed
the the radicals who developed this kind
of call it locus or political
correctness or whatever it is that
prevents me from saying that it's weird
that rachel levine
is the assistant health secretary the
people who developed this
described what is going on right now in
great detail
they predicted it and they called for it
this is this is what i outline in my
book and
and republicans and conservatives have
been utterly feckless
at stopping it because they've fallen
for the trap that these
very very clever political thinkers on
the left laid out
i do think there is a way out of this
but
i suppose you'll have to read my book to
figure out what that
trick is because it's a little bit of a
lengthy argument we'll talk about it
more on this show but
i do i do lay it out there there is some
good news though
on this big tech censorship front which
is that
one of the last great supreme court
justices
clarence thomas has given conservatives
at least cause to hope that we might be
able
to win
clarence thomas was just
the court broadly was just uh presented
with some
cases regarding big tech they did not
make any big decisions it's not like
there was some big
landmark case that just came out on big
tech
actually the court decided not to hear a
couple of cases but in making
those decisions clarence thomas fired a
shot across the bow and he
he endorsed a pretty strong conservative
argument
to stop these big tech companies from
controlling our speech and censoring
everybody
thomas compared big tech giants not to
little private companies and you should
build your own twitter if you don't like
it
he compared them to common carriers and
public accommodations
it's a good argument because they
control the flow of speech in our public
square
and in a republic speech is politics and
politics as speech
he wrote even if digital platforms are
not close enough to common carriers
legislatures might still be able to
treat digital platforms
like places of public accommodation
although definitions between
jurisdictions vary
a company ordinarily is a place of
public accommodation if it provides
lodging food entertainment or other
services to the public
in general he added that twitter and
other digital platforms bare resemblance
to that definition
now some conservatives are going to
recoil at this argument because thomas
is basically saying look
if places of public accommodation stores
hotels these
sorts of things if they are not
permitted to discriminate then twitter
shouldn't be able to either
some conservatives are going to say no i
don't like that argument because
actually you know in my really abstract
view of things
and in my ideal world the places of
public accommodation they would be able
to have freedom of association too and
this is not a conservative argument
that's why we need to lose with dignity
what thomas is doing is bringing us back
to reality
the not the way that our government
should work in
the wonderful perfect abstracted minds
of some very esoteric thinkers
some very ethereal thinkers a better way
to put it
but how the government actually works
how the society actually works and he's
saying
look the left is maybe distorting or
perverting our law they've been doing it
for a long time
and they've been using it to their
advantage we need to use the law as it
currently works
the political regime as it currently
exists to our advantage to
we shouldn't just cede the ground to the
left i think he makes a great
point i don't i don't think republicans
should shill for big corporations
as a matter of religious principle
anymore
okay we should should reward good
corporations with our
business and you know we should be we
should treat corporations fairly we
shouldn't just
wield the power of the state arbitrarily
but we should wield political power when
it is just
i'll give you an example of an
out-of-control corporation spirit
airlines
just punished uh
some travelers a young family now some
people say that traveling on spirit
airlines is punishment enough
it is in itself punishment i've traveled
on that airline quite a bit because it's
pretty cheap
there was a family young woman seven
months pregnant
got young kids special needs kid
they're all wearing their masks the
little little kid was not wearing a mask
and some crazy stewardess at spirit
airlines
demanded that they leave the plane take
a listen
what do they do i told you
non-compliance
you will have to get off i didn't want
to do this
you have to pick up your stuff what do
we do
i'm sorry
i'll make sure he wears it everything's
gonna be fine i'm sorry i'll make sure
that they're wearing it okay
special needs child a two-year-old i
understand
right i'm not my choice destroyed before
why would you place yourself going to do
this i'm sorry but she has to get up
take your stuff excuse
make the baby and the special needs kid
wear the mask beep boop beep boop
non-compliance get off no
no i don't think so i don't think
corporations should be allowed to do
that
i don't think that spirit airlines is a
private company
in this very abstract way that we like
to think of this firm distinction
between public and private i think there
is a
a lot of government regulation of these
airlines
and and the governments are bringing up
the mass mandates but in some cases the
corporations are pushing it more than
the government and
i just don't care i care about the
practical effect of this
what what happened on that airline is
unjust
should not be permitted to happen in a
just society
speaking of just societies last time i i
flew on spirit
thankfully was some some years ago now
it was when i first visited
la right now la is
calling for homeless shelters
effectively kind of mental asylums
because so many of the people on the
street are just complete lunatics
drug addicts and people who have who
have psychological disorders that
prohibit them really from living a
normal life especially if they're not
taking their meds
so la city council member mike bonan has
proposed sheltering the city's homeless
population
at local beaches on the pacific ocean
wow oceanfront property for free sounds
great sign me up where do i
where do i how do i do that obviously
the la resident's very upset about this
as a very recent la resident
i was there you pay a lot of money to
live in l.a and most people don't get to
live anywhere near the beach you know
you
if you're lucky i lived maybe i don't
know five miles from the beach that was
cool but
i certainly wasn't touching oceanfront
property now i guess i just need to
become a heroin addict and live on the
street and then i get oceanfront
property
uh no this is a very bad idea but i'm
not opposed to the idea of building
homeless shelters or really more
specifically
mental asylums this shows us
a lot of what we've been talking about
the limits of liberty we closed down the
insane asylums about 50 to 70 years ago
in the united states
out of a misguided understanding of
compassion and liberty we said it was
wrong
for these people to be locked up in
these places and we need to let them go
free and you know we've got some
medications so they can take that and
then they'll go free but they wouldn't
take the medication
and letting them go free basically led
them to living in squalor on the beach
we have mental asylums in the country
it's just under overpasses
it's just unregulated it's just in parks
and on and on sidewalks
we still have them they're just unsafe
and ugly and we get to
delude ourselves and pretend that we're
so compassionate letting these people be
free no
we're we're committing a grave injustice
we we need to have a much
more serious understanding of our
liberty not these bumper sticker slogans
that the left is pushing but which the
right has indulged as well
we need to get a little more down to
earth a little bit more practical
stop stop allowing ourselves to be
pushed around stop stop giving more and
more power
to an increasingly bizarre
liberal elite because they're retaining
more and more power each day they're not
giving any of it up
and the more we let this go on the
longer we'll let this go on the less
likely we will be
at stopping it i'm michael noel's
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. today on the
ben shapiro show the biden
administration pushes global corporate
tax increases while ramping up spending
and taxes at home
the white house signals more bullying of
corporations to come and republicans are
actually optimistic about 2022 that's
today on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen